hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
future-proof biosafety cabinets a guide
to selecting the right BSC presented by
David watt session product manager lab
crunkle corporation
I am Alexis Krause of laberd's and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to by leverage and sponsored by
lab Congo for more information on our
sponsor please visit lab Congo comm now
let's get started before I begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button once as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left
your screen this presentation is
educational and the software's
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I'd like
to now introduce our presenter David
westosha David is the product manager
for biosafety cabinets at lab Conkel
corporation Kansas City Missouri and
holds a degree in microbiology for the
university of kansas he is a member of
american biological safety association
international the controlled environment
testing association and is involved with
the NSF and anna AMS ieee standard 49
joint committee david joy lab không có
in 2015
David you may now begin your
presentation thanks and good morning
everyone I'm going to talk today about a
couple of different biosafety cabinet
types some you may be familiar with and
some that are a little bit newer to the
class 2 grouping and the overall intent
is to help you understand the biosafety
cabinet functionalities of each type and
ultimately get a better understanding
for future proofing or biosafety
cabinets for your laboratory so first
off just a quick review so we'll talk
about the class 2 types we'll talk about
what they provide for you as a user or a
lab manager how they they typically form
a function when there's an alarm and
then we'll also just go discuss some of
the functionalities associated with the
type C 1 cabinet which is a newer type
of BSC our most recently introduced by
lab Kenko through NSF 49 so jumping
right in the the first and most common
type of class 2 biosafety cabinet is a
Bay 2 so this BSC is similar to you
might have heard of a tissue culture BSC
or a laminar flow hood in your lab
oftentimes that's going to be a type a2
and what it provides is provides
protection for yourself
so airflow going away from you into the
BSC and it also provides protection for
samples that you would be working with
inside the BSC so a sterile environment
to cleanly grow a cell culture line or
operate with something that needs to be
kept clean when the air is pulled
through the BSC it's going to be
exhausted predominantly back through
HEPA filters into the DSC which provides
a sterile environment but some of that
air will go back out to the laboratory
so typically these are not connected to
ductwork now because of the
recirculation of the air back into the
lab and back into the BSC typically
these are our cabinets that are intended
for use with non hazardous materials so
no chemical vapors or if any very very
very minut amounts because they're going
to be recirculated back into the
laboratory environment if we look at the
airflow within that a to you'll notice
that this is a forward-looking or a user
position view of that work area you'll
notice that it's all a light blue color
and for the sake of this presentation
all of the areas where the areas are the
work surfaces light blue indicate areas
where chemicals must be used in
extremely my new forms if at all
course there are some times where you
have to use some sort of smelly sample
perhaps or light amount of chemical and
as a as a way to mitigate some of that
recirculation you can utilize what's
called a canopy connection this is an
NSF approved design and it mounts on top
of a BSc and allows you to exhaust air
that would normally be going back into
the room into ductwork so that it can be
removed from the building note that
still on an a2 design you have
recirculation of air back into the
biosafety cabinet so the use of
chemicals is still something that needs
to be real limited to low amounts
because you can end up with the
concentration of chemicals back into
that chamber where you're working that
may reach an explosive limit
so at some point in time there was a
amount of biological research being
performed in biosafety cabinets I cross
a threshold where realize that there was
a need for a greater amount of chemical
protection so about 3035 years ago a new
type of biosafety cabinet called a class
ii type b was introduced into the NSF 49
standard which governs how BSC should be
designed and perform goal of the type b
cabinet was to address chemical usage
that was of a level that was not safe
within an 80 type cabinet or an a.1 so
you'll notice a couple of different
design components here and you'll see
some of the air in this cross sectional
view is actually going back out to the
back of the BSC and it being exhausted
without returning back into the
biosafety cabinet if we look at how this
is represented from a user standpoint
you see a design that looks more like
the little bit of a mix between an a2
and a new type of cabinet of course
that's the B in this case you'll notice
that there is an area of the biosafety
cabinet towards the back that is red
what the red indicates is an area where
it's safe to work for attempt with
chemical hazards now this is a type b1
cabinet and type B's you'll notice
there's also a color of purple and
essentially what that is in this case is
an area where blue non-chemical paper
usage area towards the front crosses and
mixes with the area where it's
acceptable to work with hazardous
chemicals it's an uncertain area because
this this is a defined by a smoke split
line that moves depending on how a HEPA
filter loads so from a user's
perspective it's only safe to work on a
back of a type b1 cabinet when you're
working with hazardous chemicals when
you need that to be exhausted to the
outside and because of that there are a
couple of problems when it comes to user
operation first off this is a line that
is invisible to operators so while it's
nice and defined in this image in real
life it just looks like a stainless
steel work surface
silver and doesn't really indicate where
it's safe to work with chemicals or not
other thing is on a b-1 cabinet you're
you're forced to look at the very back
of the BSC
what that means is that you have to
stretch your arms out during the entire
time you're working with hazardous
chemicals and also more importantly the
the location where you're working into
the cabinet requires you to put your
arms all the way into the sterile
working area of a biosafety cabinet it
means that you potentially may introduce
excess contaminants to your BSC if your
arms are not cleaned and disinfected and
protected and it also means that you may
incorporate some of the hazardous
bacteria or chemicals that you are
working with onto your arms which makes
which can be difficult to remove and
disinfect from yourself when you move to
leave the BSC when done with your work
because of those problems users looked
for a different solution and at some
point in time a cabinet called up b2 was
introduced to the NSF standard if you
look in this BSC the entire area that
covers the working area of the biosafety
cabinet is red which means that all of
this air can be is safe to work with
hazardous chemicals on a cross-sectional
view you can see that all of the air
that enters the BSC so look front small
arrow on the outside and then all of the
laminar down flow air coming into the
BSC all of that goes into the work
surface but need to work surface and
then out through a dedicated pathway to
the outside of the building so as a
result the biosafety can that's
compatible for use with all sorts of
chemicals and no matter where you worked
in the BSC but it is the biosafety
cabinet is now exhausting all of its air
to the outside which can become very
expensive if we want to look at a list
of differences between pros and cons for
biosafety cabinets that are type B's
you'll notice that the cons list is
quite higher than the pros list so on
the pros list especially for type b2 s
these types of cabinets provide
exceptional safety from hazardous
chemicals there's a dedicated pathway
for 10
to be exhausted story to the outside in
a b1 that means you're working at the
very back of the cabinet and a b2 that
means
anywhere in the cabinet on the con side
there are a number of things to address
when looking at laboratory facilities
and operational considerations for users
so the first one is that B's because of
the way they operate with a dedicated
exhaust they must have a exhaust system
that is capable of maintaining constant
airflow without imbalance and it means
that that's typically a single duct run
and a single blower on the rooftop of
any building that's going to be
accommodating each and every B 2 or B 1
cabinet if you have a system with one
remote blower on the rooftop you ideally
you could only hook up one the cabinet
to that system if you have multiple
these valve cabinets there are instances
where one BSC may be used more than
another and it's HEPA filters to become
more loaded and all of the BSC is now on
that system that are combined with one
blow or become out of balance and cause
constant alarming issues and and
challenges for getting the cabinets to
work properly operationally there are
some considerations as well for B's that
are less favorable on a b-1 it means
we're working in the back of the cabinet
and a b2 means you can work anywhere but
should there be an exhaust failure the
system actually has to shut down within
15 seconds to prevent a situation where
air from the cabinet spills out to the
front area of the BSC and into the users
labs that's a situation called puffed
back but it also means that should there
be an exhaust failure you only have 15
seconds to accommodate and deal with
your chemical hazards before needing to
leave the area where the biosafety camp
is located and that's typically not very
practical when you may be handling
particularly infectious organisms that
you can't simply spray down in 15
seconds are left to decontaminate
properly from a facility's perspective
there are a lot of challenges with
biosafety cabinets that are type B the
first one is high design cost
so if you're going to have these type of
cabinets functioning properly you need
to make sure that you have a dedicated
exhaust and blower per biosafety cabinet
obviously very expensive so if you don't
have that it means a lot of expensive
retrofitting if you do have it that's
great but it means you paid a lot
upfront for those different organism
different exhaust runs operationally
once installed a b-1 may be slightly
more efficient because it's only
exhausting some of the air at the back
of the cabinet but a b2 is going to eat
up a significant amount of air over a
b-1 and over an a2 as it exhausts its
entire area to the outside of the
laboratory it's also known as 100%
exhaust often as the terminology
affiliated with type b2 cabinets so if
you are not air conditioning your
building during moderate temperature
months maybe not a huge impact here
overall facility costs in terms of
energy usage but in the winter or summer
months essentially a b2 is working very
similarly to a fume hood in that it
requires conditioned or heated air to be
supplied into the building and then that
cabinet is immediately taking that air
and pushing it out of the laboratory
another big important consideration with
a type b cabinet is that once purchased
b2 and b1 cabinets always have to be
exhausted with a remote blower system
that means should your work ever change
in a facility where you may not need
typical protection in a B you are still
stuck with having to exhaust the B
cabinet to the outside with expensive
air leaving the building and not coming
back
there are a couple of ways to mitigate
some of the problems with these for
instance if you don't need a full be
chemical protection you may be ok with
using an au that's canopy to the outside
Thai bays are okay for limited use and
your work warrants that a taipei may be
suitable but there are instances where
you simply need the protection from a b
and perhaps you can't work with all of
the the cons associated with a type ii
cabinet so there's a new type of BSC
that exists and it's called a type C 1
BSC this is a NSF listed BSC within the
last few years and it looks at issues
associated with A's perhaps not being
able to use chemicals of high explosives
limits and bees that have both
operational and facilities requirements
I could be challenging for users so look
at both of those a and B shortcomings
and addresses them through a number of
different ways so type C 1 offers
flexibility in terms of how it can
perform so it can operate as an ad se
that recirculates some of its air or it
can operate in a b mode where it's
exhausting some of its air straight to
the outside it's a flexible choice that
a facility manager can make on how this
BSC should perform as projects change
when ducted it's going to exhaust just a
smaller period a portion of air from the
center of the work surface which means
that it's going to significantly reduce
its overall building demand for for the
HVAC performance in terms of cubic feet
per minute leaving the building so what
that means is that you can have less
supply air which is a cheaper facility
design improvement or if you have a
building that has limited airflow
capacity you're already maxing out all
of your air in your building this
provides a little amount of additional
air required to exhaust when compared to
a type beat cabinet our type b2 cabinet
so because it's reducing the amount of
volume of air leaving the BSC out
through the system and building it means
that it's going to be
significantly cheaper to run once
installed and it also means that it it's
going to be more green over the lifetime
of the BSC because it has an internal
exhaust blower as well which is similar
to an a-type cabinet that has a blower
exhausting some of its air it doesn't
require a B type cabinet requirement
where there's got to be a single duct
run and an exhaust blower per cabinet so
type C ones can replace a fume hood they
can replace a type b cabinet they can
replace an exhausted type a cabinet
they're very flexible in the way they
can be installed into a facility so if
you're thinking to yourself wow my
building is very old and I know I have
limited capacity with my airflow I see
one would work if I'm building a new
type B cabinet and our new building and
I'm looking at type B cabinets but I'm
concerned about the total air that's
going to be exhausting house building a
type c1 would be a suitable replacement
because the type c1 can be used for
multiple purposes so exhausted or just
recirculating it also makes the process
of selecting a BSc for the teacher
fairly simple if you are unsure of
whether or not your BSC needs to
accommodate hazards of chemicals or if
it's just going to be use for tissue
culture that's a difficult question to
answer until you have the type of work
that warrants one or the other type of
BSC with a type c1 you don't have to
make that decision when purchasing the
BSC so in seven years when your work
changes or perhaps you're a contract
facility and you have a different
experiment every two weeks a type c1
biosafety cabinet allows you to
accommodate all those different types of
work that may come through a facility in
the course of its life as usable
laboratory so we're going to look at a
just a quick video that shows some of
the features of a type c1 and helps
explain how it functions as a flexible
BSC
the world glass design of the purifier
axiom class to type c1 biological safety
cabinet is the result of decades of
containment and safety engineering the
air inlet grille safety glass sash and
work surface of the type c1 have
similarities to other class 2 biosafety
cabinets
however the axioms 3-piece work surface
and chemical work zone is unique the
Kim's own provides a clearly identified
dished workspace designed to maximize
workflow efficiency while the wings
provide staging zones for unused clean
material and discarded or completed work
using the axioms my logic operating
system and LCD display the BSC can be
programmed to adapt to the needs of any
user and can be controlled by simply
lifting or closing the sash the
cabinet's supply airflow is physically
separated from the exhaust airflow and
is maintained through the use of an ECM
driven blower the axioms exhaust has a
combined ECM driven blower and plenum
and an exhaust HEPA or OPA filter the
exhaust plenum is designed to alternate
pressure based on its installation in
either recirculating a mode or exhaust
ducted beam mode
here you will find the exhaust bypass
and cover plate the inlet pressure
relief valve and a 10-inch round exhaust
duct cover learn more about the tight c1
purifier axiom in these related videos
okay so if you were watching the video
and you'll notice a couple of key things
which will address about the work
surface and the next slide but first
most important thing is there is a
segment to work surface that defines the
work area so it helps users when they're
working to outline an area where they
can work with safe chemicals in that
center area it also helps segment work
flow so for those of you or her
microbiologists and know that you
typically work with left-to-right or
right-to-left from from clean to dirty
the defined areas of the type c1 help
the users automatically do that by
showing an area where they can keep
consumables showing an area where they
can work and showing an area where they
can put their waste you'll see in this
cross-section so there's there's air
coming in through this the top blower
and then going down and then
recirculating back into the BSC and with
some of that air going back to the
exhaust so that's the areas are defined
by where you're working in within the
BSC whether you're working in that
central area or working on the outside
so if we look at the areas of the DSC
where it state to work with hazardous
chemistry well notice the same colors
are appearing here like we've covered in
a 2 and B 1 and B 2 models on the left
and right side when this is an exhausted
mode those of areas where it's safe to
work with just regular consumables and
things that are not generating a
hazardous chemistry vapors of some kind
in the center you'll notice there's a
dished area that's called a Ken's own
which is effectively an area where you
can work with any kind of hazardous
chemical like you would in a B 1 or B 2
in that right area it's important to
note that this area is really well
defined both on this picture but also
visually in person so there's not a
really a question like on a B 1 of where
it's safe to work with chemicals and you
also notice that the area extends all
the way to the front of the BSC Inlet
which means that you can operate in an
ergonomic fashion at the front of the
BSC without having to stretch your arms
into an area where it's safe to work a
little bit more on that now
you
the purifier axiom class - biosafety
cabinets 3-piece work surface looks
different than any other class - BSC the
Kim's own aptly named for its ability to
handle microbiological applications
involving chemistry is a direct exhaust
workcenter personal protective air
flowing into the cabinet and down flow
air flowing over the side surfaces of
the interior coloured blue are
recirculated through the cabinets supply
air system chemical vapors should not be
introduced in these airflow areas
err and the column above the Kim's own
coloured red is exhausted from the
cabinet in a single pass
when the axiom is in its recirculating a
mode this exhaust air is simply returned
to the lab through the exhaust interface
when inducted b-mode chemically
contaminated exhaust air is safely
removed from the laboratory
a type a BSc is not designed to handle
hazardous chemistry type of b2b SCS can
but exhaust massive volumes of expensive
room air in the process the axiom must
closely resembles the type B one
internal airflow however to work safely
in a b-1 the operator must be trained
and worked behind an invisible moving
line known as the smoke split the axiom
type c1 is the only cabinet that reduces
energy consumption while containing
chemicals and is safer and easier to use
because it does not use a smoke split
right so if we look at a cross-section
that highlights the areas where it's
safe to work with chemicals you'll
notice the red path is translated all
the way from the work surface through
the back of the BSC and out through the
top so that's just another
representation of the definitive line of
the work surface where you're working
once in that central time zone and where
that air is going when an exhaustion
mode an important part about the slide
again is looking at the the two separate
blowers and we'll get this to cover this
in a moment here in the slides but
there's a supply blower on the blue side
that's going to stay free of any
chemical vapors when working in the chem
Doan and then there is a separate
exhaust blower on the red path directly
before the DSC would provide hair into
the ductwork that's going to be critical
here in just a moment let me address
some of the added features of c1 type B
it type c 1b SCS
the concept of the type c1 biosafety
cabinet presented new challenges in
airflow design and coordination a design
that revolutionizes laboratory and
operator safety and improves workflow
performance operator safety is
maintained by negative pressure air flow
into the cabinet drawn below the work
surface into the air inlet grill this
air mixes with down flow air at the
wings of the cabinet and is drawn into
the cabinet's air supply and pushed back
down through the supply hepa filter down
flow air provides clean laminar air that
bathes the sterile work zones
above the working area the air is
positively pressurized and is measured
as down flow by the certifier to meet
NSF ANSI standard 49 requirements ere at
working height should be considered
contaminated by the work being performed
and is now drawn under the work surface
by negative pressure air above the wings
of the 3-piece work surface mixes with
incoming air and is recirculated back
into the supply air flow system down
flow air over the central Kim's own work
surface is drawn directly into the
negative pressure dedicated exhaust
airflow system
the recirculated air is drawn up the
back of the cabinet and is controlled by
the supply blower
exhaust air directed through the chem
zone is kept separate from the supply
air by a dedicated internal duct system
that feeds directly into the exhaust air
plenum the exhaust air is directed out
of the cabinet through the exhaust HEPA
filter by a separate exhaust blower
though similar in appearance to other
class to be SCS the axioms
differentiated and directional airflow
bridges the gaps between type A and type
B
so if we look at the top of the BSC
you'll notice there are a couple things
that are going to be similar to type a
to canopy B SCS and that's the first
thing is the intake check valve this is
something that is not used when the BSC
is in recirculating mode in fact it's
completely bypassed in the sense that
air is just returning to the lab to the
top but when inducted mode you'll notice
this flap is something that opens to
allow for a little bit of bypass air to
enter into the system to help balance a
remote blower on the rooftop between
which is pulling some amount of air and
and balancing between the biosafety
cabinet which is exhausting some amount
of air into that system so in normal
operation it opens up and adds a couple
of extra cubic feet a minute to to help
balance the entire ductwork system when
switching between modes there's a plate
that has to be switched in addition to a
certifier coming in and reassessing the
cabinet performance on that plate that
is switched is just left at the duct
taller and so it's just a handful of
hand screws that have to be removed so
overall the process is very simple in
order to change a biosafety cabinet from
recirculating mode into exhausted duct
mode so while it can't be done on a
daily basis it can be done from projects
project or on a yearly recertification
cycle
also there is a internal exhaust floor
that I mentioned and what this does is
it helps connect a type c 1 vs c 2
ductwork and provide air at a very low
requirement for exhaust blowers so for
those of you who have starved air
systems and don't have much air flow
left to exhaust another BSC or perhaps
you don't have enough for B cabinets
that you already have installed this
exhaust blower helps provide the exhaust
air into the ductwork at a very low
static pressure it also has a safety
feature in that it keeps continually
running if so desired it should there be
a remote blower failure to help evacuate
hazardous chemically contaminated and
biologically contaminated air out of the
BSC and into the ductwork away from a
user B cabinets that period of time
lasts for just a short 15 seconds or
less on an axiom type c1 that can be a
period of up to 5 minutes which allows
ample time to D D D can Taman 8 the
biosafety cabinet and clean up any
hazardous chemicals and other products
and then leave the the biosafety cabinet
you
omni flex the axioms ability to
between the recirculating type-a mode
and the ducted type-b mode provides
unparalleled flexibility for tomorrow's
laboratory during use the air above the
Kim's own work surface is directed to
the BSC s exhaust interface where it
leaves the cabinet in a mode it leaves
through the exhaust collar and bypass
opening however if hazardous chemistry
or odorous work is being performed in
the cabinet the cabinet should be
installed in type B mode in B mode all
of the exhaust air is removed from the
laboratory
to convert the axiom to type B mode
follow four simple steps 1 connect the
cabinet to ductwork
to move the plate from the right side of
the exhaust collar to cover the bypass
opening on the left side
three select the axioms b-mode program
to indicate that the BSC is connected to
an exhaust system
lastly have your certifier validate the
cabinets airflow
HEPA filter
and alarm operations
once completed the axiom class to BSC
and mechanical system are paired to
provide biological and chemical safety
the axiom also allows the lab to select
from two operational sash Heights the
setting can be changed when needed
through the my logic operating system no
physical alterations are required
this is flexibility that no other
cabinet type can offer
learn more about the type c1 purifier
axiom in these related videos
okay so now that you've seen some of the
flexibilities and types e1 cabinets
we'll talk about some of that safety
component that allows for some added
protection in the event of an exhaust
failure so we like to call this active
protection protocol which is essentially
the functionality of the BSC - to
maintain a face velocity that's
protecting the operators in terms of
inflow volumes during it as if exhaust
failure and you'll notice on this slide
we've got arrows representing how air
flow is moving through the biosafety
cabinet now in the event of an exhaust
failure
we'll lose pressure in the ductwork here
from the remote blower so you'll notice
that containment is maintained and
during this period of time active
protection protocol will be activated
which allows for up to five minutes of
containment at the face of the BSC
so because the exhaust blower inside
that the c1 exists what it's able to do
is maintain that phase velocity make
sure that you have five minutes of air
pumping into the DSC and then out of the
BSC into the exhaust system before that
air goes dead and the bacteria and
hazardous chemicals end up in the lap of
whoever might be using that biosafety
cabinet gentle rate that better there's
a video I'd like to show now
and it will demonstrate some of the
features of active protection protocol
the axiom is the safest class to buy a
safety cabinet available NSF tested and
listed the axiom in accordance with NSF
ANSI standard 49 for biological
protection in both a and B modes
furthermore the axiom possesses safety
attributes that exceed current
definitions for all other class to be
SCS during exhaust failure all taipei
cabinets pressurized their canopy and
exhaust duct work until manually shut
off or restarted
all type-b cabinets must detect an
exhaust failure in less than 15 seconds
and then simply shut down all internal
blowers
type c1 axiom extend safety by
maintaining operator and laboratory
protection through a remote exhaust
system failure for up to five minutes
the axiom detects such a failure within
one second and then enters the
programmed active protection protocol
during this time inflow and down flow
remain an operational range while
audible and visual alarms alert the user
to the exhaust failure and it begins to
countdown to shut off
when the countdown ends the supply
blower shuts down first and down flow
and recirculation cease
the exhaust blower operates for an
additional 10 seconds to ensure the face
of the cabinet stays negatively
pressurized before imminent shutdown
the NSF test of this system showed an
increase in face velocity during active
protection protocol when installed on 50
equivalent feet of duct with a remote
blower at its terminal end laboratory
tests indicate that the four foot axiom
can provide operational safety during
remote exhaust failure when installed on
over 3,000 equivalent feet of 10-inch
duct this innovative approach to
operational and failure mode protection
in a class to BSC with Kim's own work
surface makes the axiom as safe as any
type b cabinet during operation and
safer than any class to BSC when a
building's exhaust system fails
learn more about the type c1 purifier
axiom in these related videos
so you'll notice as a result of active
protection protocol you're able to
maintain significant amount of safety
over a type A or B cabinet so an a
cabinet will be able to run and maintain
its its operational containment
characteristics but with the negative
caveat of pumping hazardous chemicals
into the area where you might be sitting
when it comes to be cabinets you
essentially have 15 kappas 15 seconds
and then the cabinet dies and all the
things that you're working with are now
sitting in your lap contaminating
yourself and those around you so if we
look at some of the components for the
axiom that make up its functionality and
things to do be aware when when looking
at potentially adding one of these to
the laboratory you have two sizes
available
four and six feet you have to sash i'ts
8 inch or 10 inch and that's something
that you can change easily in the field
you have two functions so you can
operate this cabinet as a type a cabinet
or you can operate it as a type b
cabinet depending on the work that
you're doing so it's the only flexible
cabinet available as a class 2 BSC it
gives you type 2 types of protection
like all class 2b SCS so protects you
and it protects your product it also
gives you two types of hazard and
protection because of our HEPA filters
there are particular prevention from
escaping back into the room for any of
your bacteria or viruses or other
particulate matter and when functioning
in B mode it also operates as a vapor
protection biosafety cabinet by
exhausting air to the outside of the
building so if you look at ways of this
can augment your facility it can lower
upfront costs by reducing HVAC
requirements so keeping in mind that you
have less air flow going out of the
building when it exhausted mode and you
also only have to have one dedicated
duct run for all of your laboratory
equipment you don't have to have one
dedicated duct run per BSC you can also
avoid costly changes so if you built a
facility already and you only have that
one platform with one blower you don't
have to come in and do surgery on the
building adding 30
for $40,000 worth of ductwork just to
accommodate a type b cabinet that sees
will operate on any ductwork
you can also lower the lifetime
operational cost then you can do this by
reducing the air leaving the building
typically air can be quite expensive per
cubic foot it can be several dollars
depending on where you are we're located
in Kansas City where the winters are
moderately cold but if you're in Canada
or perhaps you're in an area where
energy is quite expensive that costs can
easily go quite up up quite
significantly you can also increase
safety by looking at removing risk
factors associated with type b cabinets
and even type 8 cabinets when working
with hazardous chemicals and that's done
through the active protection protocol
feature of a type c1 diet with safety
cabinet that allows you to exhaust air
for up to five minutes in terms in the
event of an exhaust filter and lastly
the most important part about this
biosafety cabinet is that you can
future-proof your laboratory and ensure
that when you purchase a c1 you'll be
able to accommodate all types of work
whether it's a BSC that is to be used
for tissue culture and recirculate for
its entire life or perhaps a BSC that
may need to switch back and forth from
tissue culturing to working with an
extremely explosive chemical that would
weren't typically the use of a B in past
years so at this point I'll welcome any
questions and be happy to address any
conversational topics you may have as a
result of the presentation
thank you David for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
our first question is how much air is
exhausted for type c1 BSC
yeah great question so they are most
similar to a type of A to B SC this
vented C ones are currently available in
four foot wide and six foot wide lengths
or with the four foots going to exhaust
about 480 CFM in a six foot would
exhaust about 680 I was there pretty
close to the a2 so c1 four footer would
be 480 versus 360 from a2 and 680 versus
550 for an a2 when comparing to be 2 so
the distance the the amount of air
exhaust is quite different C ones the
484 4 foot versus p2 734 4 foot so
almost double the same is true for a 6
foot as well where you're exhausting
almost 1200 CFM and a B 2 and only 680
with the c1
so we're in the process of building a
new laboratory that will carry out many
different types of experiments we have
planned to buy b2b SCS could a type c1
be used instead of a b2
another good question certainly yeah and
in fact it probably would be favored
alone for energy savings associated with
the b2 so if a b2 is on and running it's
always going to be exhausting 100% of
the tear if you have a laboratory that's
a contract research maybe a diagnostic
laboratory or clinical research
laboratory where certain assays and
experiments come in and go it's tough to
be stuck with the type b cabinet where
it's always going to be exhausting all
of its hair and costing the facility a
lot of money with the type c1 you can
drop that into an area that's been
planned for a type V cabinet so it's not
too late to switch or if you're planning
a new building and you haven't designed
anything then the c1 would give you
flexibility to work as a recirculating
cabinet like an a or a fully exhausted
cabinet when working in the Kem's own
like a V the the changeover process is
very easy so that's the recommended
cabinet if you have if you're unsure
what you're going to be working with in
the future
David how easy is it to convert a c1 BSC
over from a mode to be mode good
question I get a lot of questions so the
process is fairly simple it involves
like some of the video showed in the in
the presentation the removal of a cover
plate and switching it over to the other
side of the top of the pse so a couple
of hand screws and then going in and
actually connecting the duct work to the
BSC and then telling the BSC you know
hey you're now in either a mode or B
mode whichever you're switching to once
that process is done it's always the the
cabinet does need to be recertified so
it's ultimately a procedure that you
should plan for with the start of a new
experimental program and not something
that happens every day because you do
need a certifier to come in and recheck
that the cabinet is working and
functioning properly
but considering the though what you're
stuck with when you have a type b
cabinet where it's always going to be
forced into the exhaust mode the
procedure of having a DSC read a type c1
BSE recertified it's pretty easy to do
especially when most laboratories are
having annual or semiannual inspections
and recertifications
we recently installed several be two
cabinets onto a single blower many of
the cabinets constantly go into alarm
does the c1 have these same problems you
know that's the interesting that we
think that we we try to catch as many
times as we can when we're talking to
customers who are purchasing multiple B
2 units when you place a b2 unit with
onto a duct run that has one blower the
system will work as soon as you add
multiple B twos they cause fluctuations
between the cabinets and cause what
you're describing in that question so
whoever asked that thanks for sharing if
you if you try to work that system on a
standard blower that doesn't have any
automatic adjustment it's bound to fail
VA V's still often have problems with B
BTUs that are gained so it's still not
an ideal solution and and a lot of DAV
manufacturers may tell you that it could
work that's because they're often used
to working with fume hoods that are
getting together but b-2s still will
have issues so if you have a possibility
of switching over to a type c1 cabinet
you can gain those on a system whether
it's Vav or non-va B so the idea of
replacing the B cabinets with the type C
cabinet would alleviate those alarm
issues with without sacrificing the
ability to have a 100% exhaust area in
the biosafety cabinet
what is the inflow for the c1 in both
modes
in flow is going to be 105 so it does
not change between the biosafety
cabinets when they're operating in
either mode it is 105 nominal
and if there are no more questions
we want to thank you again David and do
you have any final comments for our
audience no thank you very much for
joining me today
I'll just advise you if you all have
more questions these videos and a lot
more information on type c1 cabinets are
available directly on the live
tomcote.com website we're all always
welcome to answer any questions you
might have so if you're in the initial
planning stages or perhaps you already
have an existing facility and you're
looking to buy a new biosafety cabinet
please give us a call and we'd be happy
to discuss any considerations you might
have in the selection process for
biosafety cabinets otherwise thank you
very much for joining before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today or those submitted during the
on demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to thank laborat and I
sponsor lab Kongo for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through March of
2019 laboratory via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
yes McGregor